all right so uh now we're gonna go on to
talk about the false discovery rate
um and it turns out that this fun data
set in the islr2 package
has um not just five managers but
actually two thousand managers um so
we're gonna load them all in gareth is
going to
do the honors here i'm going to do the
work it's his computer as you all know i
don't work with pcs so i really don't
have a choice
okay so we we read this in
and now for each of these 2000 managers
we're going to compute the p-value
okay done
and now it turns out that we can use the
same p dot adjust function to adjust
those p values using benjamini hochberg
in other words to compute what is
sometimes known as a q value instead of
a p
value so if we do that here we see that
for the first 10 managers
the first manager's q value is 0.089 the
second fund manager's q value is 0.99
and so on so we can think about this as
telling us like the threshold for fdr
control at which we would be rejecting
any one of these particular fund
managers so for example if we wanted to
use an fdr threshold of 0.1
then we would be rejecting the null
hypothesis for any fund manager that has
a q value below 0.1
so we would reject like for the first
one because its q value was 0.08989
and also for the
let's see the sixth one because the q
value was .075 but not for the second
third fourth or fifth ones
and in total here out of those 2 000
fund managers 146
ended up with a q value below 10
so how do we um interpret this q value
below 10 percent this is saying okay
well i'm saying i want to reject the
null hypothesis for any fund manager
um corresponding to an fdr or a q value
below 10 so that's saying that i
basically want a list of fund managers
for whom i'm fairly confident that most
of them really are getting
non-zero excess return did i get that
wording right yes yeah you're learning
thank you i'm a really fast learner
um so we're we're trying to reject the
null hypothesis for any
um
fund manager where i'm fairly confident
that the excess return is nonzero and in
particular
if i'm rejecting the null hypothesis for
fund manager i want to know that not
more than 10 percent of those fund
managers for which i'm rejecting the
null hypothesis are actually false
positives so to say to try to say that a
little bit more simply if i give you a
list of fund managers where i say you
know i'm fairly certain that these are
the ones who have non-zero excess
returns
i want no more than 10 of those to be
false positives that's what it means to
be controlling the false discovery rate
at level 10
and there's 146 such fund managers where
probably out of these 146 around 14.6 or
maybe 15 of them are actually false
positives but most of them
i can be fairly confident have really
non-zero access return yep exactly
okay
so
if we look at the
bonferroni cutoff
bad news bears
we we wouldn't have picked any of these
fund managers uh using uh
this and this is using the ten percent
uh cutoff here uh so if we use
bonferroni to control the family-wise
error rate at ten percent we couldn't
reject any of these two thousand and of
course family-wise error rate and false
discovery rate are really telling us two
different things family rise error rate
is saying
i don't want to falsely reject any any
any
null hypothesis corresponding to a fund
manager i don't want more than a 10
chance of any false rejection that's
just a really really it's an unrealistic
it's unrealistic yeah it's unreasonable
whereas fdr is saying okay i want no
more than ten percent of them to be
false positives all right
so we had just shown you how to perform
benjamini hofberg using the p dot adjust
function and that is a really good
strategy if you want to live an easy
life where you just let our do the work
for you but if you want to really roll
up your sleeves i don't have sleeves to
roll up but gareth does if you want to
roll up your sleeves and uh do the work
yourself instead of relying on p dot
adjust you can actually implement
benjamin hoffberg yourself that's what
we're doing now
first of all we sorted the p values then
we are having m
be the number of p values in this case
that's 2000. we're setting q to be 0.1
because that's the fdr threshold that we
want to use
and now what we're doing is we're
creating this object called wh dot ps
which stands for which dot p's and
that's going to contain the indices of
the p values
that are less than q
times 1 to m divided by m so what's
going on here well p's is this object
that contains the sorted p values
and
w h dot p's is going to contain the
indices of the sorted p values where
like the jth smallest p value is less
than q times j over m
so basically below that red line that
you had had in your
plot that you showed earlier exactly so
like the for the first smallest p value
w h dot p's is going to contain the
number one
if the first smallest p-value is less
than q over m and it'll contain the
number two if the second smallest
p-value is less than two times q over m
and so on
okay
and now
we are going to just store
the largest of those wh.ps because i
want to know
the largest p-value index that was part
of that wh.ps object and if the wh.ps
object is just empty
i just want wh to not throw an error
which is why there's this else state
this if else statement here
okay so let's do some plots
so this is just plotting the p value
sorted right from smallest to the yeah
these are the sorted p values again my y
axis shows the p values on the log scale
actually the x axis is also on the log
scale this is a log log plot
and
and now we've colored in blue
the
p values
that are
less than the
benjamini hogwarts cutoff right because
the ones that are below the bench in the
africa well that at least are less than
the last one that's below right so
remember my w h dot p's object
tells me which of the p values falls
below the red line
so w h dot p's tells me which p values
fall below the red line and then w h
tells me
the largest of the p values that falls
below the red line and that's like the
right most blue one
is the largest and so everything smaller
than that largest one i've colored in
blue because those are the null
hypotheses that we're going to reject at
a banjini mini hockberg fdr cutoff of 10
and these are the 146. yep there's 146
of them exactly
and then the green line
is no bueno that's the bonferroni
threshold again at 10 and we can see we
didn't manage to reject because that
that involves like 0.1 divided by 2000
that's just
too
much to ask of our poor p values okay
all right so
that's the manual way of doing it or you
can use the automated approach
which is the p dot adjust function with
method equals bh yep so re-sampling
approach resampling yeah this is this is
the fun part
uh well i know it's all been fun but now
we're going to attach this con data set
which is this
gene expression data set
and it consists of a training set and a
test set but for this particular
analysis we don't need that division
into a training and a test set so we're
just going to smush them together using
the r bind function if you're not
familiar with r bind it just
creates a big matrix by binding together
the rows
of two matrix two matrices yeah
and then we're also going to create a y
vector which just is going to tell us
which class an observation is in we have
to combine y train and y test again
because we don't care about the training
versus test that distinction here
and so we have a end up with a matrix of
83 rows and 2308 columns so each column
here represents a gene
okay and we're going to do it
what does each row represent gareth each
row represents an observation an
observation of a patient or yeah exactly
and and so we're going to perform
2308 hypothesis tests uh here
okay
so here we can see that there's actually
four classes uh classes one two three
and four but to make things easy here
we're actually just gonna compare two of
the classes
we're gonna
have
a comparison between the observations in
class two and the observations in class
four so all that we've done here is
we've set the data matrix x
to contain x1 which is the observations
in the second class and x2 which is the
observations in the fourth class
there's n1 observations in x1 and
there's n2 observations in x2
so
in 1 here and in 2.
okay so 29 observations
in x1 and 25 observations in x2
all right and now we can conduct a
t-test on let's say the 11th gene this
is a two-sample t-test you can notice
this argument that says ver dot equal
equals true
so there are like a million flavors out
there of two sample t-tests all of which
make slightly different assumptions and
this is just like a super plain vanilla
one where we're assuming that the
variance in each of the two classes is
the same it's not terribly important
and if we compute this t-test on the
11th gene we get a t-statistic of
negative 2.09 which corresponds to a
p-value that's
0.04119
but this p-value is calculated
under the assumption of a t-distribution
that's right which is basically very
similar to a normal distribution it's
just an assumption that it's using the
theoretical null distribution for t so
basically under the null hypothesis
we're using the fact that this test
statistic should have a t distribution
with uh let's see 29 plus 25 minus 2. so
52 degrees of freedom and a t
distribution with 52 degrees of freedom
is basically indistinguishable from a
normal zero one right so this p value is
under the theoretical null distribution
but we had to make a few assumptions to
get to here so
now we can use resampling approach to
see if that seems reasonable yeah let's
do it so we'll set the seed equal to one
so the results are reproducible
and we're doing the non-lazy approach
i'm not i'm not lazy right now so we're
gonna have a big value of b we're gonna
sort of reshuffle our data ten thousand
times we're going to have tbs be a
vector so tbs is a vector containing the
the test statistics for our reshuffle
data first we're going to set tb is
equal to n a that's just like a
convenient thing to just
set the elements of a vector to while we
are waiting to
update it
so first we initialize tbs to just be a
vector of nas
and then for b from 1 to capital b which
is 10 000
the first thing that we do is we create
what we're calling dat and that's just
like a reshuffled version of the
11th gene
using the sample function which just
reorders the elements of a vector at
random
and then we're going to
compute on that reshuffle data the test
statistic that two-sample t-test again
where this time we've just taken the
reshuffle data and we've taken the first
n1 observations
and we're thinking about that as our x1
and then the remaining and two
observations we're thinking about that
as our x2
and you saw that loop took
less than a second to compute so
for a simple calculation like this even
10 000 doesn't require
a lot of energy so
what does this tell us
well what we've found is that remember
our true test statistic was around
negative two i think
and that was called tt
and the empirical or the resampling null
distribution that we got for the test
statistic is the tbs and we found that
only 4.16
of the tbs are as large an absolute
value as the test statistic for our true
data
which almost perfectly matches the
theoretical p-value we got previously of
0.04119
this value here
so what this means is that our our
resampling p-value is 0.0416 the
theoretical p-value is 0.04119 all's
well in the world in this particular
instance it didn't really matter whether
or not we used resampling to obtain our
p-value but if we feel nervous about the
assumptions that went into that
theoretical p-value
then we can be happy to know that our
re-sampling p-value made fewer
distributional assumptions gareth sort
of jumped ahead here but what we can see
here is this figure showing in orange
that theoretical null distribution which
was again a t distribution with 52
degrees of freedom which is basically
the same as a normal zero one
distribution
and then the resampling null
distribution which is the yellow
histogram they really are almost
identical the blue line
is the observed test statistic of
negative 2.09
and it should be no surprise that based
on how similar the yellow histogram is
to the orange theoretical null
distribution it should be no surprise
that the theoretical p-value and the
resampling p-value in this case are
basically identical
just reconfirms that it's reasonable to
use the t-distribution here right okay
so i think that's it there's there are a
couple topics in the lab in the textbook
that we haven't covered today one of
them is uh tukey's test
is that right was it two keys yeah
turkey's method which is sort of a
specialized approach for controlling
family-wise error rate in a very
particular setting
and we also skipped some of the late
latter material in the
chapter
on doing
resampling with
fda resampling to compute a false
discovery right
so yeah check it out um on your own and
thanks so much this is fun yeah we'll
see if gareth and i are still on
speaking terms when the cameras turn off
yeah you won't know but i'm optimistic
yeah